hey guys it's your girl jessie i'm
finally here on buzzfeed
to read your first tweets
i've been waiting for this let's go
i'm not gonna lie i'm a little bit
worried let's just have fun guys
i really love jessie no pretense
not gonna mind i don't know what
pretense means just doing things the way
she wants
yes i am very honest i mean somebody has
to do it honest person
thank you i swear hashtag jessie is
amazing
her charisma is so powerful she's so
sexy and funny and [ __ ] talented
thank you where did that thank you come
from it is true
my charisma is powerful thank you for
the sexy i am a goofball funny and i
am [ __ ] talented i actually like the
sweet thank you thank you
i love you i don't think i could handle
how hot jesse is i'm crying
don't cry because i'm not all that hard
you know sometimes i wake up i just look
like [ __ ]
you know i'm not hot all the time
sometimes but thank you so much don't
cry
please don't cry would you mom that
little raspy thing she does with their
voice sometimes is so sexy to me
oh i know she's talking huh it's kind of
like one of my um
breathing techniques so right before i
go into a song i'll be like
oh it's still just from the black cereal
like i need to use that that was kind of
a way to like start off a song thank you
for noticing
yo official p nation get jessie on
twitter so i can thirst
over her damn it i don't think that's a
good idea to be frankly honest with you
me having twitter i probably will get
banned and i probably will get in a lot
of trouble
yeah i think it's better off that i
don't do twitter am i allowed to say
jesse is hot
yes you can that is your opinion so
thank you fam look at my queen
istg what is istg
i swear to god oh yes i swear to god she
is the baddest
in the universe i wanna be like her
thank you i believe i am very very bad i
don't think i'm the baddest
universe but i am bad but not in the
universe leaving some countries you know
me
i'm just me and i want you to be you and
the reason why i make
create these music i just want you guys
to be yourself and have your own
confidence and
love yourself and yes that's my main
goal thank you though
queen of rap hashtag jesse i saw her on
pretty rap so although she lost
she is the winner for me thank you just
because you win
does not mean you are the winner i was
in second place
and i am still very very happy and i am
still
winning don't say i lost them i didn't
lose i was in second place like i did
not lose baby
second place is good enough okay jessie
one
a literal queen two a whole package of
visual charisma sex appeal
singing and rap three has the best
clapbacks to the haters yes
don't come at me however these days have
been very busy so i haven't been able to
clap back to the haters and that is why
i can't have twitter
jessie can get it i have no idea what
this means does that mean she can get it
like
what does that mean oh like money i mean
i've been getting it
but i don't know if this person means
that that also sounds like yo she could
she's dead like violence but yeah we'll
go we'll skip this one oh
even her backy sexy crying face not
gonna lie
my back is sexy
i have this this crazy line
in my bag because when i wear clothing
and when you get back shots of me you
see that
straight line and yeah
not gonna lie next two tweets reference
to the
short review that i had with mino
watching jessie give male idols mental
breakdowns due to her
doing and saying everything a female
idol is not supposed to do is my
favorite thing
i mean listen female idol there is not
no nuts and yes there is
nothing like that i just do what i do i
am a very
free spirit person and at the time i
might have showed some titties and he
might have been like overwhelmed but it
is what it is
i had to do it watching jessie make the
male species uncomfortable with their
boobs is my new favorite thing
shout out to dr kim for uh making my
boobies
nice and firm because i got my boobs
done about six years ago
my boobs they'd be calling it titties
and uh
big old titties let me just get this out
there my boobs are not that big i'm
actually a small c
to a big b depending on you know my
menstrual
cycle i'm glad that you guys enjoy my
titties
[ __ ] if dr king gave me those those
implants i'm all floating she is
beautiful
i'm [ __ ] how do you see that shook oh my
god look at her
thick thighs i'm going to disagree with
you on that i do not have thick thighs
i'm working on it
but thank you i've been having a complex
with my legs because my legs are a
little bit skinny but i've been working
out i've been eating burger king like
maybe once a day
holy [ __ ] step on me queen
no i will not do that but i am ready
for this i waited so long for legends
for a comeback first of all i do not
want to step on anybody i've been
getting a lot of comments saying step on
me queen i would love you to choke me
i understand what you guys are saying
but i don't want to choke you
and i don't want to step on you because
i will hurt you and i don't want to hurt
you
i'm so sad that this is the last video i
wish there was more like
thirsty ones where it was like real
specific like
real naughty tweets thank you guys for
waiting for my comeback be sure to check
out
what type of eggs autumn eggs i will be
performing like a [ __ ] when you
want to work
out when you're in the shower when
you're in a drive when you're mad just
listen to the song when you listen to it
you don't feel better i promise you
[ __ ]
let's go baby
[Music]
oh